welcome back everybody actor ezra miller
is making headlines for a slew of
bizarre reports involving unsafe living
conditions grooming teenagers and a
one-year-old child child who put a
bullet in their mouth miller first made
headlines several weeks ago for
back-to-back arrests in hawaii for
causing a disturbance at a karaoke bar
and later for throwing a chair
this week rolling stone released a
report saying miller was housing a young
mullet mother and three children in
unsafe conditions at a secluded vermont
farm the report states that guns are
lying around the home including in the
living room where a one-year-old child
put a bullet in her mouth rolling stone
also says that there's heavy marijuana
use at the home in front of the children
ranging in age from one years old to
five and at the same time officials in
north dakota sent out a protective order
against miller who is yet to be located
by the court parents there accused
miller of grooming their teenage
daughter with cult-like behavior and
violence
all right bernarda i'm not even sure
where to even begin here but what sort
of repercussions could miller be facing
here in light of all these accusations
i'm waiting to hear when the department
of children and families are going to go
to the location and try to investigate
these allegations before it's too late
of course we never want to hear that
something has happened to a child or
that the police are running onto
someone's property for no reason at all
but we need to be careful because we
have all heard of those kids that have
died at young ages at the hands of
others who don't properly care for the
environment that the children are in
bernard let me just follow up with a
second how come they can't find them
i i don't understand how they can't find
them if the media can find them and uh
take pictures of him
that's a good point i mean terry look
how do you prove something like unsafe
living conditions for a child or even
grooming a teenager these are not
accusations that we hear typically and
not amount to charges that we we've
heard typically we've kind of heard a
little bit with delane maxwell
absolutely in fact i was going to
mention that with the unsanitary
conditions there's all kinds of evidence
that can be presented you can show that
there are you know a situation where the
house is kept clean where you're not
getting food where there's physical
abuse even bruises or broken bones or
there's emotional abuse so any type of
evidence where there is a condition that
is not safe for that child it could be a
range of things and you know as far as
grooming is concerned like you said just
we saw that in the billy maxwell case
that is actually defined as establishing
a relationship with that child in order
to promote some sort of sexual activity
and it could be grooming with the child
it could be grooming with the family
which it does sound like might be
occurring here and it takes place by
lowering that child's inhibitions you
try to make a friend with that child you
try to give them gifts you do all of
these things that the child thinks that
you are becoming close to them and that
you're a friend and that they will trust
you so that's what they'd have to prove
they probably use an expert in the case
if this case is actually brought to show
that all of those things have been
occurring so we'll see what happens we
will i mean these are disturbing
allegations against this man so we'll
see what happens bernardo terry thank
you so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you